hi guys I'm jammie Lee from The Pete
home show and I'm here at the NBA 2K14
release party to talk about a game about
a
game do you ever get offended when
people play as you and don't do
well whenever someone's like you know oh
I played with you you were trash I'm
like at least you played with me thanks
I appreciate that if you play the game
as yourself is that
masturbation oh that's a really good
question I know if you like slammed on
like what would you be like like what
would your saying be probably your mom
your mom I love that it's a classic boom
your mom you want to read some of these
taking my baby to round Town that's my
favorite is this Colonial Williamsburg
because I just made that basket nice
quick question can I have your boobs
like can I take your boobs and
unfortunately my surgeon died a few
years ago so no you can't what would a
video game based on your life look like
you know like in Super Mario when you
hit a wall and it lets you keep walking
even though you're not moving forward
yeah it does this thing just as long as
all the characters were naked in my game
Oh I like that and pulsating naked and
pulsating if I could just someone up
with lightning hands right that'd be
fine I don't want to fight but I just
want to be
like
I'm just wondering if you can dunk the
following things a rake a rake probably
a horse's
head yeah probably a baby wait two
babies no no no babies no the idea of a
baby yeah I got two sons okay um loose
lentils loose I don't even know what
that is so love it I love it your name
is Chrissy fit that's like the best last
name it's like you are fit and you you
are fit I'm more Jamie like should do
more squats would you make a Vine with
us really quick sure let's do it I've
never done Vine before okay wait hold on
here we go 1 2 3 go okay you we don't
even have to make a Vine we can just fix
ourselves this how do I make it you need
to play my video game which is Jamie
2K14 it's just me on the computer
thinking about cats oh I bought this I
bought the bootle I got the bootleg of
this are there lightning hands it's a
niche game it's niche
well that's it guys I'm Jamie Lee and
this has been basketball video games
carpet watch The Pet Home Show October
28th better do
it you better oh that's so weird good
advice thank you thank
you